de la boue partout des maisons ravagées
par les eaux si ce qui attendait les
sinistrés de princeton en entrant chez
eux pour la première fois depuis les
inondations
la résidence de son père venait d'être
vendu les locataires étaient sur le
point de partir aujourd'hui ils ne
peuvent qu'espérer que le bâtiment
n'aura pas à être démolie mais il
pourrait bien avoir tout perdu
la maison se trouve tout près du
croisement de deux rivières quand la
digue cd si tout le quartier qui s'est
rapidement retrouvé englouti sur la rue
church l'eau est montée très haut
aujourd'hui les résidents dépité ne
peuvent que constater les dégâts et
commencer à jeter tout ce qui a été
détruit
un cauchemar pour ses résidents qu'ils
vivaient en zone inondable pas couverte
par leur assurance mayo louti fin de
l'aide pour vider sa maison mais sa
femme n'ose pas venir voir les dégâts
tellement elle est bouleversée
à princeton toutes les histoires se
ressemblent les sinistrés commencent à
peine à prendre la mesure de tout ce
qu'ils ont perdu toi tu
as
et art ici le nettoyage et les travaux
de reconstruction ne font que commencer
de ski
le maire souligne que les gens de
princeton devront être patients et
réclame du même coup l'aide des
gouvernements pour mener
le croisement de deux rivières est
normalement ce qui fait le charme de
princeton sait bien que même après ces
terribles inondations certains résidents
ont bien l'intention de retourner vivre
tout près de l'eau avant de se lancer
dans un débat sur la reconstruction
la ville elle promet de rebâtir une
digue plus résistantes ici mathieu weill
et radio canada prenne ce thème